[Music]
hello there
season six of fortnite arrived and with
it came a new bunch of myths that need
to be chased and potentially busted
if you have a myth you'd like us to test
please pop it in the comments below and
upvote your favorites
in this episode we'll be taking animals
to the launch pads at the spires
hiding cuttlefish in secret places and
seeing if pigs
really can fly so sit your butt down for
10 minutes slap code adamaru in the
store to help out my nonsense and let's
do this
let's chase some myths a very simple one
to begin with
what happens if you upgrade a weapon
while holding
a spire orb so the new mechanic this
season is to collect parts to upgrade
weapons
to show this upgrade our character whips
out a hammer and bashes their hand
so we're going to do that but with
aspire orb which just in case you've
been living under a rock
can be obtained by defeating aspire
assassin
so now the moment of truth here's a
weapon upgrade whilst holding a knob
yep that's right the orb is used as a
hammer
great ball control penny so we tried
this with other holdable items
and the one you need to see is a chicken
i can't explain this
but i quite like it please don't patch
it out epic
i think we need to move on to those
cuddle fish pink ticking time bombs with
a proximity sensor
these things are seriously overpowered
and make for interesting plays
a few things to quickly note the
cuttlefish can't be attached to
teammates
they bounce off that happens with tamed
animals too but don't worry we found a
bunch of great ways to use them
starting with this myth from straight
out to cornwall
cuttlefish can be used in a drive-by so
let's try it we set up iron man to sweep
the streets clean
and placed cuttlefish on the side of our
ride we drove past
at top speed no slowing down at all the
hope was the cuttlefish would be
triggered by the enemy when passing by
and here's what happens
okay that is impressive the cuttlefish
activate as intended
but the delay in jumping to the enemy
means the vehicle can be a safe distance
away before they explode
officially the cleanest drive-by in
fortnite history
with zero evidence left behind unless
they don't die
then then you need to shoot them let's
take this upper level
burns asks can cuttlefish be thrown
through
car windows great myth hiding cuttlefish
inside vehicles so we jumped in a car
and smashed the windows with our faces
we then tossed in a few cuddle fish we
hit a failure moment here as the
cuttlefish simply stick to the windows
even when they're non-existent this myth
was busted
but wait we remembered the windscreens
could be removed with a few bullets
could a cuttlefish be thrown through
here hell yeah it can
the cuttlefish can exist inside any
vehicle and should an enemy decide to
jump in
eventually boom
a self-contained explosive we tried this
a few times and if the cuttlefish
are well hidden this tactic is actually
viable
we also noticed that if the enemy came
close but didn't get in the vehicle
the cuttlefish would leap towards them
repeatedly but remain stuck
inside the car in a later test the
cuttlefish inside the car
still jumped out of a moving vehicle so
we could still perform a drive by
so a few grey areas to note but in terms
of a meme strat
this method of hiding cuddle fish is
worth a try
next myth from aaron
who asks can cuddle fish be hidden
inside hiding spots
hiding those pink blobs in the loo the
haystacks and the trash
this one is pretty easy to check when a
teammate opened a potter potty
i threw in a cuddle fish and for a
moment it went
inside and this looked like a success
but
a few moments later the fish explodes
regardless of who's around
on other hiding spots the fish sticks
out openly and becomes too obvious
so this is a busted myth
here is a great myth will animals
use the spire boost pods i hope this is
proven good
at six spots on the season six map are
broken spires
with a launch boost pad sort of thing at
the very top
they are great for rotating into the
next storm circle
and by the way if you haven't tried yet
use one whilst holding a chicken
it's mind-blowing but for this one we
need a wolf
i quickly tamed a wolf and took him to
the spire and lo and behold what
happened
he loved it he's having so much fun i
sat here for 30 minutes watching this
guy
he never stopped true legend quickly
moving on the next myth is from a ton of
you guys who ask
can a vehicle be rifted for this one we
jumped into a private game and quickly
earned the gold to buy a rift
from raz i tried to buy the rift from
the back seat of the truck
but alas now we can't do that this
season so another approach was needed i
stood as close as i could to the vehicle
my teammates and the npc
and look what happened when a rift is
purchased
everyone except raz is dragged into the
air even the vehicle you're in
there is absolutely no reason to do this
in game but this is what we do here
completely pointless myths ggs everyone
now for another myth which we all want
to be true and again helps nobody at all
can an animal rock it right so many
people asked for this
so i started with the ball i used a
crash mat to bounce him up in the air
and took
pot shots
as you can see it technically works but
almost immediately the bar falls off
again
i think we need at least two seconds of
flight time to confirm this myth
this was my second strat i tamed the
ball and walked him up a ramp
and then quickly edited and dropped down
below to do this
the boar is officially rocket riding
pigs do
fly the journey comes to an abrupt end
with a bang
and without realizing we also chased a
new myth do
animals take fall damage
i can say with quite a lot of confidence
no they don't
we turned our attention to the wolf
species and this was somehow way more
simple
i once again threw down the crash mat
and we took turns to fire the beast into
orbit
and then it was my goal
it's totally possible and this is one
thing you must do before the season ends
it should be an achievement it's a shame
the replay file stutters like this but
it was enjoyable to watch
the wolf leave the atmosphere
[Music]
the brand new remote amazing cube landed
in the stall this season
a rubik's cube remote which got many of
us thinking
is it possible to complete the cube this
isn't a huge stretch to be honest the
bottle cap kiki moat had a percentage
chance of success and so did the burpee
emote of changing to a literal burp
and the hula hoop one too so what about
the amazing cube
for this one i jumped into battle labs
for three hours and left my game running
when i returned penny was still trying
to solve the cube
checking back on the replay file shows
over the three hours she never manages
it
and from closer inspection the cube
doesn't change at
all the same blue purple orange and pink
blocks
can be seen at the end of every
animation in the same order
so this is 99 confirmed to be a busted
myth
we aren't clever enough to beat the
amazing cube just yet
but i wouldn't put it past epic to
update the emote with a tiny chance of
success
i'll be sure to keep checking it over
the season anyway let's crack on
before our last myth take this one moon
key man says
myth can you kill someone by throwing
the orb i tried
nothing happened we cannot eliminate
each other with the spire orbs they
simply travel through the person's body
but we can have fun playing catch happy
fun times
and now our final myth antoni dim asks
myth
what happens if you lure an animal into
the steamy stacks cooling towers
let's do this i started by taking my
favorite wolf to the stacks
and to cut a long story short this
happens
absolutely nothing the wolf roams around
openly on the purple stuff
next we take the chicken over i was
confident the chicken would fly into the
air due to their wings
but alas it's another busted myth rip
the dream
to make this a full house i took a bar
over and watched them fight to the death
in the purple coliseum
the wolf attacked the chicken the bar
attacked the chicken the chicken chased
them both away but in the end the wolf
took the dub
like there was any doubt so there we
have it another bunch of myths chased
busted and confirmed in season six of
chapter two
thanks for sticking around to the end
and an extra special thanks to these
guys
who rocked my code this week code
adamaru thank you very much much
appreciated
i'm adam from playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure see you next time
[Music]